hey guys how's it going we're back here
with another iPhone update we're talking
about the iPhone 7 the previous iPhone
video that I did was about the iPhone se
I did an unboxing and for those of you
who may have missed the update in a vlog
that I posted afterwards I did return
the iPhone se for me I am more of a
larger screen type person and I did make
a mistake not necessarily a mistake but
I may have misspoke by saying that the
iPhone se is a basic phone because it
clearly is not it is a higher-end phone
it's one of the more higher-end phones
that are currently on the market right
now as far as Apple is concerned it's
basically the iPhone 6s plus shrunk down
into the casing of the iPhone 5s so with
that being clarified let's hop into some
new iphone 7 rumors a bunch of you guys
were tweeting me and saying Justine has
been confirmed there is not going to be
a headphone jack in the iPhone 7 so
let's see what we can find
if Forbes says it's true it's gotta be
true this is what April 14th is
currently April 15th we already see this
this looks like a lie I mean is that a
case is that a clear case Apple iPhone 7
line of smartphones which at successive
history iPhone 6s shouldn't be announced
in September 2016 oh but there's many
leaks about the iPhone 7 already
surfacing let's see where this link goes
I just I'm sure it's something that we
already saw already three iPhone types
one with a dual lens camera which we
said would be the iphone 7 pro it dual
lens I've actually haven't seen this yet
the removal of a 3.5 millimeter
headphone jack
I just I'm still unsure of how I feel
about it I mean I don't think it's
really gonna make that much of a
difference especially if there is a
lightning connector that you'll be able
to connect existing headphones if that's
the case it's not going to be a big deal
I still in my car have one of the old
iPhone chargers and it has a connector
that converts it to the lightning cable
so it's really not that big of a deal
but it is a little bit of an
inconvenience plus is another thing that
you have to buy Apple also recently
received a patent for detachable
wireless lighting devices patent
highlights headphones they can accept
audio signals to record in one mode
Bluetooth and our
it was the same let's keep going that's
just I'm that's a lot of text we're
closing that here's a little mock-up of
what the potential bottom could look
like without the headphone jack a
Japanese Apple news blog Mac what have
you got to say are you in English no but
that's okay because I can see the
pictures previous rumours suggested the
iPhone 7 could have the same six foot
one millimeter depth as the iPod touch
they said the iPhone 7 will likely be as
thick as the iPhone 6s and the antenna
bands will not be visible on the back of
the devices it's basically going to
essentially just look like this
without the bands and a dual camera and
also no headphone jack I can get down
with that iPhone 7 release date and new
features and rumors or what have you got
what have we got
okay a tree life of course it's hoping
that it has a better battery life but
truthfully I'm not going to get my hopes
up 16 gigabyte will surely be it has to
be phased out honestly if they keep
continuing to make a 16 gig phone you're
insane you're crazy
no one can even update or do anything or
take photos or take videos especially if
you're shooting at 4k like that is just
one video can end up being like five
gigs the iPhone 7 could get a USB C port
hmm I definitely think that's also
unlikely the change from 30-pin to
lightning is recent enough and was a
painful it was super painful I mean I
still like I said to have some of those
thirty pin to lightning connectors in my
house let's squash some other rumors a
3d screen no curved display potentially
they're not going to do a curved display
flexible there's no way edge to edge
screen I could actually see that bring
out gaming John Watts who the hell even
thought that a spring out gaining
joystick in the home button would be
something that Apple did if Apple
actually did do that I would die I would
probably pass out and just be like I'm
done I wash my hands of everything
wireless charging quite possible I have
a feeling they're probably not gonna do
wireless charging even though I think
that they really should because
most phones now do do wireless charging
there's so many different other options
for wireless charging there's all kinds
of like the power mats where you plug in
a little dongle into your phone and then
you place it on said charging mat which
is cool but it's not really convenient
that ball sticks to its traditions we
can accept the iPhone 7 to arrive in
mid-september iPhone 6s and 6s plus were
unveiled on the 9th of September and
released on the 25th so usually there's
a good week or two in between time for
the pre-orders our money is on a 6 7
13th and 14th of September since it's
usually Tuesday or Wednesday
clear your diary I will new phones twice
a year holy moly way to make sense they
just already released the iPhone I see I
keep on called the 5s it's the SCE hello
here's this is interesting iphone 7
design remembers Apple would keep the
headphone jack but make it slimmer Apple
is not able to announce in September to
the iPhone 6s or 6s plus are the
thinnest iPhones ever in fact they're a
bit thicker then their respective
predecessors because they had to squeeze
the components to power 3d touch and
some extra I love a blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah iPhone 7
buttonless design I think there's
probably less probably not going to
happen
3d touch may provide Apple with a way to
eliminate a home button on the phone one
barrage of the stevia touch ID which is
integrated into the home button
currently Apple would need to move the
touch ID reader to potentially the side
of the phone yeah it's they're not going
to do that
I don't think curved wraparound screen
that just I that looks like a I don't
know what this looks like I'm not
I feel like if Apple did this right here
I think the uproar would be quite loud
the a flexible no patch ID built from
the screen mmm possible I just don't
think it's gonna happen here's a patent
for a fingerprint sensor incorporated
display into an electronic device
that was filed in 2014 sapphire glass
apples already using sever glass the
Apple watch they were supposed to do
that before but as they were saying here
Apple was backing a plant could have
been used manufacture 200 million 5-inch
iPhones per year but the company has now
declared bankruptcy and was unable to
meet Apple's demands Cameron for that
was a whole thing iPhone 7 to be
unhackable
mmm waterproofing and an official
waterproofing this time some claim by
the Chinese microblogging site that
Apple was testing out waterproof designs
with evan 7 they have to I mean like how
am I supposed to take a bath and not be
afraid that I'm going to drop my phone
into the water because it is a
legitimate concern
iPhone 7 could dry itself by shooting
water out of its speakers a radical new
solution to the water logging issue a
mechanism where the iPhone can dry
itself by pumping water or other liquid
through the speaker of its gross wet
finger support even if Apple doesn't go
for a fully waterproof design we can see
Apple introduced a new feature that
allowed a user testing with wet fingers
I don't know why I think that's funny
iPhones have a new feature self-healing
ports what if the ports were covered but
you didn't need to take anything out
before plugging interesting wireless
charging yeah that's kind of neat look
at this so that would be like a little
power mat you just set it on there this
actually did happen to me the touch ID
fingerprint sensor have been overheating
causing the home button to become
burning hot that kind of scared the crap
out of me I like picked my phone up and
I want to unlock it and I was like oh
burning burning my finger I don't know I
wasn't actually upset about iOS 9 making
people use six digit passcode because
honestly that's a little bit more secure
so why would you help
- not sure I feel about the gesture path
code kind of always annoys me on Android
a gen processor could be a 6-quart
possibility with the iPhone 7 would look
like if Apple was a democracy
this is amazing thanks everyone for all
of your petitions and suggestions pants
trap shatterproof viewmaster Android
antenna holy crap a punch card reader a
CD but oh my god
ear trumpet jack mag save MagSafe to it
oh my god this is amazing
what is this iPhone 7 concept
illustrations this has the freaking uh
what the heck do they call it the crown
wheel or whatever the hell on the Apple
watch that would be wild
this looks good that looks absolutely
fantastic those colors are hideous don't
even think about it I like that little
silver around the edges let's see if we
could find anything else so it is worth
taking the peek at it really looks like
everyone is saying that it's not gonna
have the headphone jack so I feel like
that's gonna be the biggest change let
me know what you guys think in the
comments below about the iPhone se did
you get one do you know anyone that got
one what are your thoughts also let me
know your thoughts on the potential no
headphone jack in the iPhone 7 I think I
would be ok with it but I definitely
already have a lot of headphones that I
really like and I'm not going to
necessarily want to bring around an
adapter to connect so that I can just
use headphones I'm not sure this is
going to be very very interesting so I
look forward to seeing what Apple's
going to be doing that announcement will
probably officially take place in
September which is it's April we still
got a little ways as always be sure to
tweet me any Apple news did you guys see
or anything else that you think that I
would enjoy you can follow me on twitter
at a justine if you're new here I'll see
you guys in next video bye it's not in
here Maddy borrow my glasses where are
they